so we know that last week's spy balloon
came from China but what about the three
other objects shot down over the weekend
well apparently U.S Pilots could not
even identify how these objects were
even being powered or staying in the air
so we seem to know nothing anyway
joining us now with reaction a former
Navy pilot he previously encountered an
unidentified flying objects Ryan Graves
is with us Ryan welcome to the program
uh I know NORAD is saying this that it's
a possibility I don't doubt that it is a
possibility I've studied it I've looked
into it I find it an interesting topic
I've not been convinced that you know
life exists elsewhere or what these
unidentified flying objects are but you
testified before Congress why don't you
tell people what you said
yeah Sean I think at the end of the day
I agree with you that we really just
don't have enough information right now
to make an assessment either way of what
we're looking at what we do know is that
there are things out there that are
posing a Aviation safety hazard and now
we're seeing that Hazard demonstrated in
real time in Alaska and Montana and
elsewhere and across the United States
okay you testified you're you're a
former FAA team pilot and you said that
50 to 60 people that you flew with would
tell you that they saw a UAP every
single day yet one other pilot has
confirmed this publicly but you're
saying that this was something you often
all talked about privately
absolutely we would fly our Jets off the
Eastern Seaboard in our working areas
with our f-18s and once we upgraded our
Radars we started noticing objects in
our working areas that we weren't
expecting to see
and we were all seeing these we're
seeing them on our Radars we're seeing
them on our camera systems and our FLIR
systems and eventually we even saw them
with our eyeballs it came to the point
where we almost had a mid-air with one
of these objects as we were entering our
areas which forced us to file a hazard
report or a hazard to report to the rest
of the fleet that there was a safety
issue that we were experiencing out
there and the air through that saw this
object just described it as a dark gray
or Black Cube inside of a clear sphere
well go into a little more specificity
in detail what the type of things that
you saw and 50 or 60 other Pilots that
you spoke to say they saw
yes when we were off the east coast
typically how we'd see these objects
behave is stationary which isn't very
exciting but typically when we're
operating at altitude we could have wind
anywhere from 60 knots up to 120 knots
operating
anywhere from about five thousand about
five thousand to thirty thousand feet
okay and so they would be stationary
wins and these objects
correct and they would be stationary uh
Against the Wind uh as if they weren't
moving uh when we're fighting to keep
our aircraft in the area other times
they would proceed in a straight line or
in a holding pattern uh often that
speeds up up to a supersonic 1.0 Mach
and they would also be out there all day
where our aircraft would typically only
last for about an hour hour and 15
minutes when we're flying tactically
these objects will be flying at high
speeds for most of the day
wow amazing experience first of all
thank you for your service thank you for
sharing your story and you know the fact
that they don't know about the three uh
that they shot down over the weekend is
spectacularly frightening to me because
um the fact it shows a vulnerability I
never thought this country would have uh
we appreciate you being with us thank
you sir hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else